Okay.
So that's a good,
that's a good place to go next.
So you laid out a whole slew of reasons,
a slew of consequences of fatherlessness and we'll return back to the causal
relationship between men do and these beneficial outcomes.
But if you could go on now to tell us what it is that men are doing at a micro
level,
then we could return to the causal link between that and the positive outcomes.
And you said those also caused some contention in the household?
Yes.
You know,
give one example,
for example,
will it be
father is rough housing with the kids and the moms looking over and saying,
looking at scans and thinking,
okay,
when should I interfere?
When should I not interfere?
And the mom saying herself,
Jimmy,
you know,
um,
please keep the kids away from the,
the credenza there,
Pete,
that gets away from the couch because they could hit their head there.
Why did she wait?
They to tomorrow when you can take this outside.
I feel much safer with the kids shit.
And then the mother is sort of hesitating to not be overly controlling.
And yet at the same time she's feeling she has to monitor.
Um,
the husband is bell as monitor the husband with the kids and she's feeling in
the back of your mind,
like I,
sooner or later there's going to be a myth.
There's going to be an accident here and I'm going to be upset with myself for
not being stricter.
But on the other hand,
the kids seem to be having fun,
so I should let things go.
Well,
you know,
there's a,
there's a cycle biologist named Jaak Panksepp who was one of the world's great
biological psychologists and he studied rough and tumble play in animals.
So rats,
for example,
a huge part of the,
the socialization process that's key to the development of the prefrontal cortex
in juvenile male routes in particular emerges and matures as a consequence of
rough and tumble play.
And one of the amazing things that Panksepp discovered it,
and this truly is an amazing thing,
is that,
um,
if you,
if you pair two rats together and then let them play repeated bouts,
the big route will dominate the little route to begin with in the first bout.
But if the big rat doesn't let the little rat win about 30% of the time in
repeated play boats,
then the little rap won't play anymore.
So you get an emergent morality in emergent plays,
centered morality,
even among rats as a consequence of rough and tumble play.
And that rough and tumble,
I did a fair bit of research on rough and tumble play about,
oh it's probably 20 years ago now,
15 years ago anyways.
And it's really quite clear that rough and tumble play helps children
parameterize their bodies so that they know how they extend and,
and,
and also what limits the reason,
the use of physical interactions with another person.
What's fun,
what's provocative,
what's pushing it too far,
what's painful.
And of course kids love rough and tumble play as well.
They're,
they're just absolutely starving for it.
And we've squeezed it out of the kindergartens,
the nursery,
the elementary schools,
the junior high schools,
all of that and for and for bid.
And what Panksepp also found was that if you deprived juvenile routes,
have the opportunity to engage in active rough and tumble play,
that they showed symptoms that were broadly analogous to those of attention
deficit disorder in human boys and that you could also treat that with Ritalin
the same way in routes as you could with boys.
So there's that rough and tumble play issue.
You know,
and you might think to the question is one question is why might a mother be
distrustful of the rough and tumble play episode?
And some of that might be sensitivity re with regards to the kids,
but huge part of that also is trust on her trust with regards to the father.
You know,
cause it's rambunctious and noisy.
And if she trusts,
let's say that that act of masculinity that plays rough,
then she'll stay away and let the fund happen.
But if there's distrust running through the family,
then then she'll stand between the kids and the father and then he won't get to
involve himself in that way and then he'll turn off.
And I've seen that happen many,
many families.
Okay,
so there's rough and tumble play.
That's a big one.
What else is,
what else do you see?
Let me take the,
the evolution and how rough and tumble play goes and all the,
the,
the dimensions of where the slippery slope that it leads to.
So the father,
the what the mom,
either the mom or the dad knew is that this rough and tumble play leads to the
types of things that you just mentioned,
but you're also evident in,
you know,
an elephants and so on.
But it also leads to the distinction between a child being able to distinguish
between being assertive versus aggressive.
So the,
so the kid starts,
for example,
maybe,
Oh,
kicking the dad and the of the wrong place or poking the data and the eyes are
pulling the dad's hair and the dad says,
I'm sweetie,
you can fake,
you can fake it.
I contacted the left and then move to the right to win in this wrestling match.
Or you can,
um,
you know,
you can do this,
this and this,
but you can't do these things.
And if you do do these things that will stop
the rough housing.
Yeah.
So there,
so there is a really important issue there.
So two things there.
So imagine that,
imagine that a rough and tumble boat is like a dance.
Okay.
And the point of the dances so that both people are having a good time while
it's happening because otherwise it's not play right.
And as soon as either party is no longer having a good time,
you've actually snapped out of the cycle biological function of the play
circuit.
So basically what you're telling the child by putting those rules on is we can
interact physically within a very limited set of parameters and you,
what you have to learn to do is to be sophist a sophisticated player within that
set of parameters.
And you want to learn how to push the boundaries,
right?
Because the most fun,
rough and tumble play is right on the edge between assertiveness.
And aggression,
right?
So,
and you can see kids,
like I used to work in daycare centers when I was a kid when I was 1819 and the
kids would line up to rough and tumble play with me because that was still
allowable then.
And they were so desperate for it.
It was just ridiculous.
And I could really tell the difference between the kids who had engaged in that
sort of play and the ones that hadn't.
And the ones that hadn't,
we're painfully awkward and they would hurt themselves.
And you,
when you wrestled with them,
they'd put their thumb in your eye or,
and they would cry often too when they got surprised but not hurt,
you know,
because they couldn't tell the difference between just being startled and being
hurt.
And so they were fragile.
And that also made them not fun to play with.
And the thing that's so interesting about that too is Piaget talked about this
when he talked about the development of children is that,
you know,
the more sophisticated pretend play and then sophisticated cognitive player that
emerges say between five and seven.
And then with the cognitive play older than that is that unless you have that
underlying psychomotor embodied dance down,
you don't get to really proceed in a sophisticated way to those higher levels of
play because other people don't want to play with you.
So the rough and tumble play,
the importance of that can hardly be overstated.
So
absolutely.
And,
and the framework here is that when you set up a system where you said that men
are part of the patriarchy,
their,
their desire is to dominate women and make rules to benefit at the expense of
them at the benefit men at the expense of women.
You have a framework,
an emotional setting,
which does not,
is not conducive then saying,
here's my value or women saying,
let me see what the checks and balances of parenting is that leads to the best
of you coming out in the best of me coming out,
all of that has said we skipped over and inherent sense of father knows best to
father knows less.
Um,
and,
and we've,
uh,
and so the,
the,
the process that I'll be sharing in a moment of what rough housing leads to and
the slippery slope that happens when it doesn't happen,
um,
is,
is what is not even been nurtured as a possibility to be articulated in this
culture.
I also think too,
you know,
that if you have a,
a partner who hasn't been played with,
then that partner can't tell the difference between Boisterous rambunctiousness
and aggression.
And if there's a hypothesis about domination and the patriarchy running its
course underneath that,
then there's going to be conceptual confusion about the physical interactions
that have the appearance of submission and dominance because that's part of the
rough housing play routine.
It's going to that that is going to be viewed through a lens of tyrannical
interaction rather than just good fun.
And I mean you can tell the difference because if the kids are rough and tumble
playing,
they're unbelievably enthusiastic about it and engaged and laughing and giggling
and like they'll play to the point of exhaustion because they need it.
They need it so much.
But that's a hard thing to observe from the outside if you're not accustomed to
that.
And if you don't have that framework of,
of um,
of men having,
and dad's having a value to begin with,
absolutely not.
So here's,
here's maybe what might be helpful for a mom to understand at the rough and
tumble,
pray,
play,
play.
We now know,
helps children distinguish between being assertive and aggressive.
But a number of other things off also happened during that play,
which is that is a bond that is created between the father and the child.
And in almost every and doing expert witness work to help children have both
parents.
You have to divorce.
I've observed more than 50 families and,
and usually the father interacting with the children and in almost every case,
every case action.
Actually I believe that I have seen there's this,
this bond is used by the father to say things like,
okay,
um,
no more rough housing.
Now tell you what,
you get your homework done,
you get your chores done,
you get all ready for bed,
brush your teeth,
teeth,
brush,
whale.
And um,
the bedtime is nine o'clock.
Whenever you get all that done,
we'll have between the time you get it done and the time of nine o'clock in
order for you to have some more fun either with rough housing or reading my
favorites,
favorite story or whatever,
whatever you prefer.
It's your choice.
Well,
you know with with Panksepp's work too,
he found that the little routes,
the routes will work to enter a play arena because,
because play,
you think play is a so Panksepp established very,
very clearly that there is a primary play circuit in mammals.
It's a separate psychobiological circuit.
It's not exploration,
it's a whole different motivational drive,
but that the APP but activity in that circuit is intrinsically pleasurable.
And part of that appears to be because it's so key to proper socialization that
it,
it's regarded by,
by children and by social mammals as intrinsically valuable.
And so it makes perfect sense that that can be used as a source of primary
reward.
And I think your comments about the the man and the kids binding themselves
together through play is also really important because one of the things that I
do with young men who,
you know,
I think young men tend to be somewhat alienated from infants who are under about
nine months old because they're not really equipped to know what the hell to do
with them.
I mean they can learn and they can be good at it,
but it's not their domain of natural expertise.
But once a kid hits about nine months and starts to be able to imitate and to
pound and to,
and to play and to respond to gentle teasing,
like that's a perfect time for the father to swoop in.
It's very helpful for a mother by the way,
who wants to have another child and to start really cementing a relationship
that's based on that interest in combination of,
of High Energy Fun plus the disciplined interactions that are necessary as a
precursor to that.
And if you interfere with that,
then you stopped the farther from being able to form that pro from liking his
kids.
Really.
You know,
because that's how the liking comes about is,
is through play.
And so it's,
it's crucial.
It's crucial significance.